Yesterday we began the topic of
circumcision.
And we mentioned
that the correct opinion with respect to
the ruling
on circumcision.
Meaning it is
wajib, mustahab, mubah, makruh, haram.
The question is with respect to males
and females, what is the final ruling we
arrived at yesterday in our research
with respect to circumcision?
Does anyone remember?
Obligatory for men.
And then mustahab for females. Okay.
And
we mentioned that the author gave us an
evidence and his opinion was that it is
obligatory for male and female.
And that is going based on a principle.
An original principle.
What is that original principle?
The original principle tells us that
as the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said,
he's the one who taught us this
principle.
It is
an-nisa'u shaqa'iq ar-rijal.
That women
are the
second half of men.
So whatever men are commanded with,
women are commanded with.
But the
commandments of the Quran and Sunnah
are most usually directed to men.
Why?
Because
they are most usually the ones who are
intended
primarily, and second of all, because
they are in charge of the women. They
are the ones that direct the women.
And so,
anything that a man is commanded
with, a woman is commanded with, unless
there is an evidence to exempt either of
the two genders.
Right?
An example.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala commands the
believers with hijab.
Does this apply to men and women?
it applies to women. So, we have an
evidence to exempt men.
Vice versa. Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
makes it permissible
for
a person to the believers to marry one,
two, three, or four.
Is this specific to men or for both men
and women?
Is this specific to men? So, you get the
idea here. However, Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala says
that he commands the believers to be
obedient to their parents. Is this
specific to men or is this men and
women?
Both.
Why? Because the original nature of all
commandments is it's for men and women,
unless we have something that exempts
one or the other. So, the author goes
based on that. He goes based on that
original principle, that whatever
whatever men are commanded with, women
are commanded with, as well. And he uses
generalized evidences in that sense.
However, we mentioned that this is a
weaker opinion
for a number of reasons.
Number one,
the evidence is that Ibrahim
was the one who circumcised himself and
it has no mention of either his wife or
his concubine being circumcised.
Number two,
this was something that did take place
in the time of the prophet
and the companions. They did
circumcision for males and females.
However, the evidences for circumcision
of females are far less and far more
obscure than the evidences for males. A
third thing is that the purpose
of circumcision for men and women are
very different. They serve very
different purposes. Okay?
For men,
circumcision is for hygiene.
Primarily for hygiene.
Because the male
appendage has that additional skin that
goes off and it becomes a harborer for
urine and
infection and all kinds of things. And
so, removing that becomes part of the
sunan of
in order that a person
not be plagued with those kinds of
things.
However, for females,
there is no such hygienic purpose for
the
circumcision.
Circumcision on females is not
done on even the same anatomy. It is
done on critically different anatomy.
For females, it is just a tiny
portion of the clitoris is removed, just
just barely nicked as the prophet sal
[Arabic recitation]
time, just just barely nicked. And the
purpose that this serves is to help the
circumcised to curb
ex- excessive sexual drive.
It is not to be completely removed. It
is to be completely left or to be barely
[Arabic recitation]
wasallam, he says,
khudi
minhu walatunhiki.
There was a woman that was that
circumcised in the time in his time,
the females, and he said, "Take a
bit, but do not take entirely."
Walatunhiki.
This is prohibited. Not only is this
prohibited, but it is positively haram
for this to be done.
There is a type of
very primitive,
very aggressive, and very
oppressive
circumcision that is done in parts of
northern Africa,
in parts of Egypt, which is referred
to as
a pharaoh
circumcision on females. And that is
that they completely remove the clitoris
entirely, all the way to the to the
base, and then it is sewn up in its
place. This is positively haram and can
be counted as a major sin and is not
permissible to do or
to practice.
And so, because of that, because these
two circumcisions, they serve very
different purposes,
very different places are being
circumcised.
The genitals are very different. And
third of all, the evidence is it becomes
very difficult
to
use the evidences for the obligatory
circumcision of men
to extrapolate that to be obligatory for
women. It just it just is a very weak
type of evidence in that sense. There
are critical and fundamental differences
between the two practices.
Therefore,
we mentioned that it is
wajib for males, mustahab for females,
or mubah. Some scholars have mentioned
mubah and that is the
majority
of the fuqaha of Islam
are of the view that for men men, it is
obligatory, for females, it is either
mustahab or mubah.
The author says, "And it is
preferable that circumcision take place
on the seventh day of
the child's birth."
[Silence]
Due to the narration which was collected
by
Al-Tiyalisi rahimahullah
in his Musannaf.
he narrates that Jabir said that the
messenger of Allah sallallahu alayhi
wasallam
he did the aqiqah or he slaughtered
for Al-Hasan for the occasion of
Al-Hasan's birth and also for
Al-Husayn's birth and he
also circumcised both of them on the
seventh day of their births
respectively.
Now, Al-Husayn is the younger brother
of Al-Hasan. So, these are two separate
instance incidents. So, we see from that
that this is a pattern. This is a
sunnah, right? one time
could have been, you know, open to
suggestion, but being that twice this
occurred on two separate pregnancies,
two separate births, this means that
this is intended. He intended to
slaughter and to
perform the circumcision for both of
them on the seventh day.
Now,
there are narrations
speaking about the circumcision of the
Prophet Muhammad himself sallallahu
alayhi wasallam.
There's a number of narrations.
Some narrations mention that he was born
circumcised.
That he was born circumcised.
And that this is,
you know, usually passed off as a kind
of miracle and a miraculous part of his
birth.
All of the narrations
regarding him being born circumcised are
fabricated narrations, all of them.
They're all
extremely weak or fabricated. Kuluha
mawdu'at.
Other narrations mention that he
circumcised himself when he became a
prophet. All of these narrations are
either weak or fabricated as well.
Rather, the opinion that the majority of
the scholars are upon and historians
and Ibn al-Qayyim mentions it in his
book Zad al-Ma'ad
and his book
Tuhfat al-Mawdud
is that
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
was circumcised by his grandfather Abdul
Muttalib as was customary in the time of
his birth.
And we have historic evidences that he
was circumcised by his grandfather
as was customary
for the children of his time,
especially someone of his position and
of his
status as being born into such a
such an esteemed tribe, such a reputable
tribe.
And so the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam
carried this tradition on and he
circumcised his grandchildren al-Hasan
and he circumcised al-Husayn
because this is something that people
know how to do, so they do it. You take
your child to a barber, correct?
And you have their hair get cut.
And if you know how to cut hair yourself
then you do what? You you
pull them into the bathroom and
cut their hair right there in the
bathroom, right? And the same
thing with circumcision. You take your
child to the circumciser, the village
circumciser, if not, then you do it
yourself if you're able to do that. And
this was what was customary in his time,
a tradition carried on
in the
time of Islam. So, we will finish this
next
following portion
where the prophet
says seven things are part of the sunnah
when a child is born. Seven things,
seven rights
are done when a child is born, are part
of the sunnah. We'll deal with this
narration
in reading it and explaining it tomorrow
inshallah.
[Silence]
Tomorrow
Fajr will be at 4:15.
[Arabic recitation]